hello everyone and welcome to a
brilliant attacking game from round four
of this year's Reykjavik open uh it is
Dina bellancaya a woman International
Grandmaster versus a Grandmaster Gregor
gayevsky of Poland and we've seen a one
game by Dina on this channel but it was
not chess it was chess boxing her chess
boxing game against Andrea botes and it
was it was quite uh quite a thriller if
you haven't seen it I do suggest you
check it out uh really an interesting
mixture and it was uh very very intense
up until the last moment you really had
no no idea who's going to win but this
is the first actual chess game that we
are showing by Dina and her opponent for
this game is a very very strong Grand
Master Gregor gevski like I said who was
uh anand's second in his 2014 World
Series championship match against Magnus
Carlsen so I imagine he is quite the
theoretician and he was on in second for
a couple of other events uh after the
the world championship match against
Magnus Carlsen so not an easy matchup
for Dina and also there's quite a bit of
a raiding difference for some reason I
forgot to include his rating but I'm
gonna add that so just give me a second
so some 300 rating points rating
difference which is always very
interesting and makes for uh more
exciting games so let's check it out
Dina has the white pieces and she opens
with Ponte E4 uh Gregor opens with Pawn
to C5 he goes for the Sicilian Defense
with Knight to F3 Knight to E6 and now
Knight the C3 so not going for D4 right
away first Knight to C3 we have Pawn to
A6 and now okay you're expecting D4 now
but Dina first goes for Pawn to G3 and
okay B5 you know that the bishop G2 is
coming so you want to counter with
Bishop to B7 Bishop G2 uh Bishop to B7
and now Bishop B7 and now Pawn to D4
striking in the center see characters
with Knight captures on D4 and now you
could continue just
um yeah that
pursue a more uh developing game or you
could go for for some complications with
Pawn to B4 and this is what gregors goes
for he plays Pawn to B4 we have Knight
the A4 and now Knight to F6 so now the
Knight is on a bit of a weird square but
it's all known Theory so here we have
castles uh and uh Bishop captures on e4
so Dina sacrifices a pawn here with this
Castle's move and uh well it's very
interesting why she does so Bishop
captures Bishop captures with nine
captures and now uh there are over a
hundred games in the big database where
this position has been reached and
rooked the E1 is the move here however
she goes for Pawn to C4 and it's only
been played in a handful of games and
now uh how do you continue Knight to C3
and knights the C5 uh is a known move
and also B captures on C3 Alpha saw is a
known move and interestingly those are
the two top engine moves but here uh
Gregor is probably weirded out by this a
little bit and he just continues with
Bishop to E7 and it is not as of move 11
then we have a completely new game so
let's see how Dina plays this he she
starts with Rook to E1 puts pressure on
the knight uh Pawn to F5 defends the
Knight keeps the Knight on the E4 square
and Dina says Nope that Knight has to go
Pawn to F3 so should weakens her a
king's position a little bit but the
Knight is removed from such an active
Square Knight back to F6 and now it
actually plays this spectacular Bishop
to G5 which uh doesn't seem like it's
doing all that much but it's actually
preventing black from castling the
problem is if black castles now then she
has Knight captures on F5 she wins back
material and you can't capture if you
capture then just Bishop captures Bishop
captures and queen D5 check picks up the
rook and A8 so very tricky stuff so here
uh is how how Gregor's deals with this
he plays King to F7 now the point is it
seems like it's not stopping the idea
because Queen D5 still comes with check
the problem is after Knight captures you
going to play e captures and after
Bishop captures you're gonna play King
captures and now the F5 Pawn is defended
and the queen D5 doesn't really do all
that much you can still play it but just
Knight the C6 so it's not a problem King
looks weird on F6 but you've gained so
much material you don't really care
so instead she plays Queen to E2 now
puts all that pressure on the E6 pawn
and here we have King the G6 and now the
problem is although it seems like the
king is perfectly fine here the bishop
is attacked you you can just play
something like H6 you can you can move
the king the position is now winning for
Dina but you have to play a very precise
move here so feel free to pause the
video and try to find a winning idea for
Dina while I give you a couple of
seconds
okay
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on sporting this
incredible uh attacking maneuver and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Pawn to G4 that's the move
that you have to play and that's the
move that Dina played and now it's not
easy to to figure out how to go about
this position the problem is if you play
something like H4 and I'm sure you guys
have considered this then just H6 and
once the best removes you're just gonna
play something like Queen to A5 bring
the queen into the game at some point
move to King to H7 bring the Rook into
the game Castle artificially and you're
perfectly fine however after this G4
move it's not as clear uh on on what to
do here how to continue to do capture
here which kind of opens up your king do
you actually capture the piece so there
are many things to consider do you
ignore all of it and just play Pawn to
H6 also can be played uh here Gregor
accepted the challenge and he played
King captors on G5 the engine says okay
it's it's an okay move uh the engine
doesn't really like the position all
that much for so none of the moves are
are all all that great but Okay g
captures an F5 this is what she had in
mind now he plays King the H6 we have F
captures on E6 and now Queen to A5 and
now uh he's attacking the Knight here
but
um uh he doesn't really care about this
Knight Dina doesn't care about this
Knight you you and you and I don't
really care about this like we even
forgot the Knight is even there so
there's no point in actually defending
the Knight and she plays Pawn to C5
which prevents the queen from going to
the king side uh with Tempo and sort of
uh protecting the black king and now you
you could capture an A4 but uh let me
just quickly show you what happens if
Queen captures an A4 then it's a force
to Checkmate in 14 moves and it goes by
the by the name of Knight F5 check King
H5 you're first gonna gobble up the G7
punking H6 Knight F5 another check
you're going after the bishop King H5
Knight captures and now after you play
something let's say King H6 now comes
Queen E3 check King the G7 Queen G5
check king f8 queen captures on F6 with
check King 87 check uh you're gonna
capture with the Knight or with
something like King captures on D7 now
comes Queen to D4 with check and now it
doesn't really matter what you play of
King to see the seven then Queen to D6
if you go uh uh king8 then you're going
under the mask of the of the rook and
now after Knight to F5 checking to f8
and now Queen to G7 will be Checkmate so
there's only one of the lines about
every line pretty much ends in Checkmate
another thing you could do is play
Bishop captures on C5 this kind of uh
hopes uh you will be in time to move the
bishop maybe even with check and then
bring the queen to help out with the
defense but Queen E3 check comes and
that's the only move that wins but it's
not a difficult one to find since it
starts with check and usually a move
starting with check are the first one
that we check uh okay maybe first moves
that we check are the ones that actually
capture pieces but um maybe uh checking
moves coming a close second so King G6
now Knight captures on C5 Queen captures
and now a nice King to H1 with the pawn
covering the F7 Square Rook to G1 will
be deadly it doesn't even matter if you
capture still look at this rookie G1
checking F7 Rook characters on G7 with
check completely shattering Black's
defenses Rook to G1 check King F7 and
not just Queen to E6 with check king f8
queen captures with checking the eight
Queen captures an h8 with the check and
now you can see that you can pretty much
gobble up everything you're now up to
pawns but uh you don't really care about
the spawns the black king is wide in the
open Checkmate is coming very very
quickly so that's how you would do it so
after this C5 move uh Queen captures an
A4 not so great Bishop captures and C5
not so great even though Bishop captures
and C5 is the top engine move uh here
Gregor's goes Knight to C6 which makes
sense you kinda defend the bishop in
that line that we've discussed Knight F5
Falls by Knight captures on E7 but now
Knight to F5 check King to G5 and here
uh you'd probably think Dina now
captures an E7 and then continues the
attack but no Dina continues the attack
uh not caring about the Knight on F5 so
just sacrificing everything this game
King captures an F5 now Queen to D3 with
Chuck Knight to E4 and now Queen
captures on e4 King F6 we have Queen to
F4 with check King to G6 and now King
the H1 now the Rooks are coming into the
attack and there's no way to defend this
finally gregors does get to play H6 but
not just to Rook to G1 with check and
you cannot defend if you go King H7 Rook
captures on G7 with tracking captors and
queen to F7 will be Checkmate as the
pawn and Rook prevent the king from
moving so instead after Rook to G1 check
he plays Bishop to G5 but now Rook
captures on G5 H characters and now
Queen captures on G5 with checking to H7
and now you could just play Rook to G1
she decided to go uh
a bit of a different way Queen H5
checking the G8 Queen to F7 checking to
H7 and now Rook to G1 and he was in this
position on move 31 that Gregor
dragevski resigned to the game as there
is nothing more to be done here
Checkmate is threatened here the queen
is all the way on the queen side the
Knight cannot help and if you try to
bring the Rooks for example Rook to G8
the stop check made the then Queen to H5
is just mate as you've taken away the G8
Square from the from the black king So a
very very interesting position where
gregors managed to get his Queen into
their game but only only for a little
bit he was looking for for freedom and
all he found uh was a tomb on an A5 for
a forest Queen so very very interesting
so just uh basically sacrificing
everything and it's uh very very
impressive way of beating an almost 300
high rated opponent so very nicely done
by Dina we'll see how she does it in the
rest of the tournament but this was uh
quite quite an impressive attacking game
uh so I hope you guys enjoyed it nicely
done against the anand's former former
second gregorge gayevsky of Poland I
would like to thank the London system
kavi halimadi Marco still Stephen
Connell and the revolution reptiles
YouTube for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and
everything that happens in the Chess
World thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day